il y a tout juste un an le monde entier
avait les yeux braqués sur Pékin et
notamment sur la place
timen parmi les étudiants qui faisaient
souffler sur le pays inv vant de liberté
quelques leaders dont une femme Shing un
rappel avec vonique
taving la militante quiang la foule des
étudiants
PL l'exil à son arrivée en France entre
ces de images 10 mois de
10 mois de fuite avec au bout du compte
l'exil pour elle et son mari un exil
qu'ils ont l'un comme l'autre du mal à
accepter pour Pékin ce sont des
criminels activement recherchés
principale figure du mouvement le nom de
Ching apparaît à la 3è place sur la
liste des 21 étudiants les plus
recherchés juste derrière un autre nom
celui de W l'autre grande figure de la
révolte étudiante pendant les semaines
qui ont suivi la répression du pin la
police a tout mis en U pour les
retrouver leur nom leur visage on défilé
la télévision chinoise leur seul crime
avoir cru le temps d'une révolte que la
démocratie pouvait s'installer en
Chine jusquici réfugié aux États-Unis
souhaite maintenant lui aussi s'établir
en France pour lui comme pour Ching pas
question d'oublier les 200 victimes
officiellement reconnues par les
autorités
chinoises 12m